here with reaction louisiana senator
john kennedy is with us senator am i
wrong in thinking that
as the united states of america it's one
of the best countries not a perfect
country but the greatest country god
gave man and don't you think it ought to
be possible for every state in this
great union of ours to be able to get a
vote count done in within 24 hours
like other countries get tens of
millions of votes counted
yes and to restore
confidence in our elections sean we have
to do
at a minimum three things first
we have to defeat as we have so far
president biden's attempt
to establish a federal election code
number two we have to go back
to having an election day
not an election month
i'm okay people want to vote by mail
that's up to the states
but the ballots need to be in and
counted
by election night let me say it again we
need an election day
not an election month and number three
you you and this is this is
unconditional
you have to to be required to prove
you are who you say you are
to vote
and if we would do those three things i
think people would have
a little more confidence in our election
system
i would like to say something sean about
you yes i'm sorry oh you go
you mentioned
you mentioned oil and inflation
uh president biden was inaugurated on
january 20 of last year
so we are on day
488
of buildback better
so far
the policy failures from this
administration
have gushed like an open fire hydrant
you mentioned oil
the president is clearly obstructing
america from drilling
for its own oil and
for environmental reasons he says
instead he wants to us to buy oil from
foreign countries those foreign
countries transport that oil to us
in tankers
that use 2 000 gallons of fuel per hour
and emit eight tons
of co2
per hour
the the irony is rich i mean that's a
special kind of stupid
that's on inflation
yeah that's a special kind of keep going
you're on a roll i'm not stopping this
uh
well well on inflation here's what the
american people see
uh president biden gave americans three
six hundred dollar stimulus checks
and then
for his next
trick
he crashed their 401ks
and increased their gasoline bills by
800. their food bills
by by 3 000. and their rent by two
thousand dollars a month
now unless you have untreated mental
illness you know that is not a good
trade
and and that's why most americans at
least on the economy
would right now would not trust
the body administration to properly open
a paypal
its economic illiteracy is astounding
you know i know what it's like
early in my adult life to live paycheck
to paycheck and that was for some period
of my life and i had spent all my money
on college ran out had to go work you
know i was a contractor i worked in
restaurants i did all that stuff that i
told people a hundred times about
but i will tell you it's not a fun
feeling senator now we have nearly
two-thirds of americans in that position
that frightens me and what makes me even
more frightened is the
i don't see a bill clinton moment coming
i've been saying this bill clinton era
of big government is over the end of
welfare as we we know it the quote
sister soldier moment i mean bill
clinton clinton had an ability to adjust
and adapt to conditions that were
unfolding in his presidency i don't see
that quality
in joe or the entire democratic party
for that matter and that scares me for
the future i'll give you the last word
on this
well quite the opposite uh
president biden says that he has no
control over over gasoline prices and
oil prices
you can't have regulatory control
over the drilling
transport
storage
uh refining
trading and taxation of oil as the
president does and accurately make that
statement
and the american people just don't
believe him because it's just not true
senator always great to have you uh
you're up for re-election i don't even
really mention your race because
ever you're so loved in louisiana i
predict right now i think you're going
to win by double digits however
i always warn people never take every
any vote for granted so we we will
follow your race more closely as time
moves on thank you sir go go to go to
john kennedy go to john kennedy.com
john kennedy.com
to learn more about my race all right
senator kennedy always great to have you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else